[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce premier
cyan par les spores de l'année à 2022 je
vous souhaite une très bonne année et
surtout beaucoup de sport et surtout la
santé ici on est obligé de porter les
masques vu les conditions sanitaires du
moment au programme aujourd'hui comme
toujours une dose de bonne humeur des
analyses sportives et surtout des coups
de gueule et des débats nos chroniqueurs
sont avec nous sur ce plateau et via
écran interposé suite au contexte
sanitaire présentation en musique on
commence à ma droite il est en très
grande forme en ce début d'année il est
surtout très studieux car il a bossé
cette émission à fond et on va souffler
qu'il avait repris récemment le sport
les commence cette année de 2022 sur de
très bonnes bases le capitaine yann
dujarrier est avec nous bon souvent
michael meier veut
comment allez-vous super bien en effet
c'est vrai que je suis déjà à deux
séances de sport depuis le 1er janvier
et on né le 5 janvier et 3 demain donc
voilà ça fera un jour sur deux par faire
de commencer sur de très bonnes bases se
faisait partie de vos résolutions ou
pascal et 2022 exactement l âge de trois
semaines de course à pied jusqu'à
jusqu'au 20 20 janvier et après on verra
si on retourne en salles de sport ou
je vois enfin voilà la selas et en mise
en place affinera occurrence des mois
pas d'objectif c'est juste pour pour la
formaiton plaisir on continue notre tour
de table à gauche musique lui aussi ils
commencent l'année sur de très bonnes
bases ce passionné de sport italien a
passé un très bon réveillon du 31 sans
excès pour être en grande forme pour
l'émission en 2022 on continuera à
l'appeler l'italian lover jagori caméras
de tv 78 est avec nous bonjour michael
très bonne année très bonnes années yann
très bonne année à toutes et à tous
comment allez vous écoutez très bien on
débute l'année on espère que les
conditions sanitaires ne vont pas au
frais le sport delmas canal masque c'est
un retour du masque qui n'était pas
forcément espérait on va on va espérer
en tout cas que l'année sera sportive et
qu'elle pourrait aller jusqu'à son terme
une résolution peut-être pour 2022
peut-être mieux m'alimenter juste avant
les vacances d'une petite blessure
musculaire je pense qu'ils étaient du
saïan apparemment il est très sport là
cette année je lui demandais juste après
l'émission on continue par nos invités
en visio musique il a passé
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année ce
rugbyman et golfeur est de retour en
2022 plus fort que jamais au sol dans
cette émission le gladiateur il nous
vient tout droit des contrées à
versaillaise pierre chevalier du
rugby-club de versailles est avec nous
pendant une heure comment allez-vous aux
pierres salut les amis mais ça va plutôt
pas mal solidaires avec le masque à la
maison mais vous l'avez huit ans je vais
encore
je l'enlève samarrai pas manquer c'est
petit
ces petites sessions mauvaise opé
distance pas du tout et vos résolutions
pour 2022
suspens du sport et dise pas que du
sport
on termine par notre dernier chroniqueur
en visio musique on a gardé le meilleur
pour la fin chaque minute passée à ses
côtés n'est pas une minute de perdue en
2022 mais bien une minute de gagner vous
allez respirent la joie et la bonne
humeur c'est notre cocktail anti-déprime
coach genlis est avec nous pendant une
heure
bonjour à tous comment allez-vous une
excellente année à tout le monde
votre résolution pour 2022 et
on continue et oui on continue à musique
d'accord donc je vous attendais pas
alors votre résolution pour 2022 2022
mais qu'on se sorte que cette merde a
trouvé le message est passé le sport
normal
et surtout beaucoup de rugby mais
j'imagine oui une envie de tous les
sports que le rugby mais tous les sports
que tous les sports en prennent à leur
place
alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission va parler de football et de
la première titularisation du versailles
et edward michu dans le onze du paris
saint-germain lévy noix de 18 ans a joué
en 16e de finale de la coupe de france
face aux amateurs de vannes victoire 4 à
0 le jeune milieu de terrain a même
touché la barre transversale en fin de
match il a déclaré après la rencontre
s'entraîner dur pour ce genre de moment
la question sur ce thème peut-il
s'imposer au psg oui ou non
non pour yann dujarrier vous timorés
pour pierre chevallier
partage également grégory et jean vous
êtes non plus bon voilà alors pourquoi
vous êtes partagés grégory partagé parce
que moi il est encore jeune 18 ans cette
année il a eu que deux apparitions avec
le psg vingt-sept minutes jouées très
exactement avec le paris saint germain
alors le psg semble miser sur sur ce
joueur c'est aussi important pour le
club de la capitale d'avoir des joueurs
formés au sein et bien du centre de
formation il a 18 ans il a renouvelé son
contrat jusqu'en 2025 maintenant qu'est
ce qui me laisse perplexe c'est que pour
le moment on va le voir que face à des
petites équipes là c'était contre vannes
en coupe de france il a eu sa première
titularisation il a été pas mal il s'est
pas caché il a même pu failli marquer il
aurait pu il aurait pu marquer un but et
il ay la télé il a tapé la barre
transversale moi je pense que sa
progression peut passer peut-être on
aura l'occasion d'en parler par un prêt
alors dans un club de ligue 1 quand même
je pense qu'il faut qu'ils tout de suite
côtoie le très haut niveau c'est un
élément intéressant je pense que le psg
mise sur lui pour l'avenir mais à ce
stade là et ce qui peut devenir est-ce
qu'il peut s'imposer dans ce psg
actuellement dans sa sont difficiles
parce qu'il ya quand même un effectif
pléthorique et de très haut niveau ps
jean pierre chevallier vous aussi vous
étiez partager partager à peu près pour
les mêmes raisons que le grain parce que
le contexte fait que sur un match ou de
france contre unique est bien moins
classés c'est une occasion de se montrer
c'est pas eu l'occasion dé forcément
briller quand on a le canton à
l'effectif du psg c'est un milieu de
terrain qui est qui est assez jeune qui
est jeune et qui évoluent là où il ya de
gros embouteillages même si actuellement
les stars du psg sont pas forcément très
assidue sur les matches c'est pas n'est
ce pas c'est pas sur des coups comme ça
qu'il va pouvoir tu vas pouvoir
s'installer c'est dans la durée et
justement va pas durer je pense que le
sur certains postes de milieu le
l'horizon est un petit peu bouchés par
contre ça fait partie de la formation
francilienne puisque puisque le jeune le
jeune maire daniel est un produit de
cette formation francilienne maintenant
il y a encore beaucoup de de championnat
que joue le gentil le psg ça détendrait
qu'on le voit tout de suite en ligue des
champions mais en coupe de france pour
l'instant peut-être en championnat après
il aura peut-être l'occasion de rappeler
quelques minutes de jeu de là à
s'imposer il en repart bien trop tôt
pour le dire yann
moix j'ai été un peu plus catégorique
parce que en effet aujourd'hui je pense
que le l'effectif du psg ne laissera pas
la place à un jeune joueur comme comme
celui ci et pourtant c'est bien dommage
parce que le psg va être champion dans
très peu de temps et peut-être que
justement sur la fin de saison il serait
bon de faire tourner de faire tourner
mais comme l'objectif du psg et de
gagner la ligue des champions les
joueurs ont besoin de jouer tous
ensemble donc pour un très jeune joueur
c'est difficile de faire de faire sa
place et puis aujourd'hui depuis depuis
maintenant un an ou deux ans alors je
sais plus mais il n'y a plus il n'y a
plus la coupe de la ligue qui permettait
aussi de faire de faire un peu de
turnover là il n'y a plus qu'une seule
coupe et c'est la raison pour laquelle
les gouro clubs de ligue 1 la joute de
manière beaucoup plus sérieuse que ce
qu'ils ont pu faire ces dernières années
il ya on en parlera avec avec air ça et
tout à l'heure mais il y avait très peu
il
ces attaques et mutuelles de finale il
ya très très peu de clubs en dehors de
la ligue 1 jean qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de ce petit edouard issus 18 ans
pas
très bien à personne simplement j'ai dit
non tout a été dit avant moi voilà dans
l'effectif du psg je pense que c'est
simplement parce que ça fait partie de
la formation des grands clubs de faire
rêver encore de dire on met quand même
les jeunes joueurs on va chercher pour
un petit peu les faire un truc bien
élevé mais ce garçon là aussi talent
adieu l'histoire avec l'effectif que le
psg a actuellement ne jouera pas jouera
pas tu es un garçon qui sera peut-être
certainement si les bombes prêter d'un
globe mais il sera pas dans l'effectif
du psg c'est tout et pour moi c'est ça
fait partie de la formation tout
simplement grégory on peut aussi noter
les propos de paul chez tino à son coach
à la fin du match qui a dit que c'était
un élément très intéressant il a salué
et aussi chez simons non mais non mais
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
en tout cas il ya une estimation de la
part de son coach on lui a posé la
question il a répondu maintenant c'est
vrai que peut-être que le prêt je pense
à à court terme c'est la solution de
télé quand même lié au psg jusqu'en 2025
un de nos vins sont liées à peaufiner
son premier contrat en 2020 premier
contrat professionnel qui a été
renouvelée donc ça prouve aussi que le
psg lui fait confiance il a renouvelé
cet été alors que son contrat courait
jusqu'en 2023 ils ont pris les devants
et renouveler le contrat jusqu'en 2025
donc ça prouve aussi que le psg peut
être à quelques espoirs prendre quelques
espoirs en ce joueur
donné de très bonnes indications dans
son d'andorre son professionnalisme des
nerfs dans dans la préparation qu'il est
capable de mettre en place etc il doit
montrer qu'il fait des très bonnes
choses pour ça il le fait à
l'entraînement donc le club a confiance
en lui maintenant le problème c'est fait
que l'effectif est trop important et il
faut pas oublier enfin il a quand même
fait un bon match
un match dimanche à lundi c'était lundi
il à faire il a fait un bon match donc
c'est vrai que dès maintenant en face
c'est une équipe de vannes pierre
chevalier
faut pas oublier aussi que la réponse
est finalement lui qui l'a juste avant
la prolongation de contrat blond de
parler de parler des algues il ya failli
partir parce que justement justement
c'était c'était bouchonné devant il y
avait il y avait pléthore de stars héros
de bones de bons joueurs au milieu de
blg et que la saison dernière la saison
dernière il ya eu il a eu
quelques minutes pour jouer face à dijon
je crois pour celles pour pour faire
essayer de se faire une place à se faire
un nom là ces quelques minutes de plus
en coupe de france face à vannes c'est
pas c'est pas le même niveau ce qu'on
peut lui souhaiter en tout temps en tout
cas ces deux sites le psg aille le plus
loin possible voire au bout comme
d'habitude en coupe de france pour
qu'ils se fassent une du temps que jean
qu'il y ait du temps que très rapidement
un petit mot sur son physique 1 m 75
elle est quand même assez frêle quand
même pour son âge il faut qu'ils
prennent je sais pas du duc du gabarit
peut-être il ya du jard y est vous qui
êtes notre spécialiste sport en ce début
janvier le gabarit je vais prendre
l'exemple de valbuena il veut dire
c'était pas un très grand joueur en
termes de taille et lionel messi n'est
pas non plus très très grand bien sûr
que à 18 ans il est parti il n'a pas
fini sa croissance musculaire il était
arrivé à sa hauteur max mais il lui
reste encore du volume à prendre bien
sûr qu' il faut commencer à manger du
poulet et des oeufs
tous les repas et et puis le reste se
fera naturellement mais on peut pas non
plus aller contre nature dans ce dans le
cadre de l'augmentation du volume
musculaire a joué aux côtés de marc
opératique aussi un joueur qui est très
petit qu'un centre de gravité très bas
pareil voilà c'est peut-être de musette
est un peu plus costaud quand même
vraiment il est costaud à la car il ya
des grosses cuisses voilà ces périodes
heures mais oui oui n'ont pas le même
âge et là le temps encore de ce
dépassement chromatique si je vais du
basket au football à mes 75 ça va on
verra ça dans les prochaines années
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de cyclisme le parcours du
paris nice 2022 a été dévoilé il passera
par les yvelines coup de projecteur
également sur le boxeur yvelinois tony
yoka qui a annulé son combat mais avant
de parler de ces thèmes on va continuer
à parler football
[Musique]
on va donc parler football et de la
coupe de france ils l'ont fait les
versailles se sont qualifiés pour les 1
8e de finale de la coupe de france en
terrassant la roche sur yon à domicile
le score est sans appel 4 à 0 et les
quatre buts ont été inscrits en première
période on écoute la réaction à la fin
de la rencontre du jeune défenseur et
capitaine de 22 ans mêle de juvigné au
micro de tv 78 c'est certainement parce
que ça fait déjà trois puis quatre ans
que je suis là en seniors
on n'est que le huitième de finale avec
l'aide de cette équipe avec beaucoup
joueur de
on s'est rencontrés ans il n'y a pas
longtemps il ya six mois
alors ce parcours est historique pour le
club le précédent record était un 16e de
finale réaliser en 1948 face au fc
gueugnon les versets y avait perdu à
l'époque 4 1 que pensez vous de cette
qualification messieurs tout d'abord
super content surtout surtout
avec la manière 4 0 c'est pas un match
qui finit aux tirs au but qui a été
difficile etc ils ont pété en plus ils
ont fini le match à la 45e ils ont mis
avec quatre buts sur 18 ans dont donc
super papinade de la gauche
voilà j'ai pas et j'ai pas le nom qui a
joué je tiens à le préciser avec grégory
qu'elle allait à l'époque à ivry sur
seine mais on s'est côtoyé plus à
l'entraînement qu'en match on a fait je
crois un match en tout et elle rappelle
que vous êtes garder à ce qui vous a mis
d un but comme ça au sûrement je m'en
souviens pas forcément mais c'est vrai
que le but en fait magnifique c'est
l'action à retenir la chose à retenir
c'est bien sûr la qualification aux
sociétés qu'on n'a pas les images parce
qu'on n'a pas les droits
grâce à ce but versailles qui était on
va dire ce versailles la roche-sur-yon
qui était pas la fif la plus reluisant
de ces 16e de finale est bas sur
eurosport notamment qui a diffusé le
match tout de suite on a mis en avant ce
but et ç'a permis de faire parler de
versailles parce que ce but il est juste
sublime c'est le but de ces 16e de
finale si vous avez l'occasion de le
revoir sur le replay d'eurosport il est
magnifique même publicité de grégory
pour faire d'eurosport jambes qu'est ce
que vous en pensez cette qualification
et c'est bien pour un club vidéo puisque
or sans appel 4 0 ok ça vous sur courir
à ce score
comment ça vous surprend ce score
surprend un match un match quel qu'il
soit n'est jamais gagné à la valse là
ils ont fait ils ont fait le job en
première mi temps 4 buts d'avancé le
match était plié à la mi-temps
une surprise je ne pense pas moi je les
voyais gagner peut-être pas autant mais
je le voyais gagner après quand même
leurs adversaires étaient invaincus
depuis le début de la saison 1 je tiens
à préciser
chevallier ce que j'aime dans ce dans ce
match et dans son épilogue c'est que
tout a été respecté par rapport à la
logique la logique sportive
le côté entertainment et les spectateurs
parce que là on a frôlé les 2000
spectateurs
on avait encore le droit a bon dos rond
et puis le scénario le scénario ils ont
été ils ont été tout aussi prudent avant
le match que est un sport pendant le
match et ça nous donne ça nous donne une
leçon une leçon de football avec mon
père
[Musique]
c'est encore un petit club qui était
inquiété en face mais comme vous l'avez
rappelé un temps qu est il a ça ouvre
non seulement un record historique pour
le procès vers ça qu'on coupe de france
peut-être on va en parler après
peut-être un petit peu plus loin mais en
tout cas ça a été une très belle logique
et une très belle un très beau match et
notamment ce but c'était merveille de
reprise demain quel endroit et c'est
effectivement même même surprenant de le
voir à ce niveau là alors le tirage au
sort a eu lieu ce mardi à 4 janvier au
prochain tour versailles va affronter
l'équipe de toulouse à domicile mais pas
forcément à mon bureau on en parlera
peut-être un petit peu plus tard grégory
l'équipe de toulouse est actuellement
deuxième de ligue 2 et ils sont en
course pour la montée la question sur ce
thème est ce que c'est un bon tirage
pour versailles oui ou non voter
alors non pour vous à grégory nos pour
vous également à yann
vous est mitigé en visio alors jean
pourquoi
alors pourquoi je suis mitigé deux
choses
alors c'est ces bornes sportivement
parce que mais ils ont quand même une
chance de pouvoir accéder
au tour suivant et ça l'est moins en
question affiche parce que c'est vrai
que 1 toulouse c'est pas cette pub et
j'ai
directement au vu du sujet c'est sûr que
s'ils avaient eu versailles psg pour la
fiche la renommée le le prestige c'était
fabuleux après sportivement c'était
quasiment à lui quasiment on paye
l'orchestré du bal est sur le terrain
c'était quasiment la fin de l' aventure
là avec toulouse mais portes il ya un
accord il ya quant aux titres joués par
semaine
moi je
suis de l'avis de jean à peu près les
mêmes raisons
et si je me dis qu'on coupe de france
pour que le que le trajet soit bon il
faut qu'à un moment donné on prenne des
gros hôpital et quitte à avoir une
chance de les faire tomber donc là en
l'occurrence en huitièmes de finale il
n'y a plus que des mots quasiment ou
qu'il reste deux clubs donc la moins
bien classée et sinon c'est que dès que
des chefs de deux leaders de ligue 1 et
à ce stade là une fois le record
historique de versailles battu une fille
c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu l'espérer
rangs de l'om prendre nice comme le psg
qui m'ont pour que la chine soit la plus
belle possible parce que en huitièmes de
finale évidemment avec le nombre
d'équipés qui lie à est plutôt ligne de
ligue 1 il ya beaucoup moins de chance
de passer un tour donc quitte à ce que
ça soit le dernier autant que ce soit
autant que ce soit contre 1 contre un
gros avec une très belle affiche
peut-être la plus belle qui aurait été
alors c'est pas faire c'est pas faire
injure non plus au tfc qui est deuxième
de ligue 2
mais c'est moins prestigieux en coupe de
france en 8e de finale de coupe de
france que de prendre le psg ou l'om par
exemple maintenant c'est vrai qu'il ya
une petite lueur d'espoir
marsh fera faux survolé versailles et
laruns et peut-être que contre 1 contre
une ligue 2 même en deuxième position il
ya peut-être plus de chances de passer
en quarts
grégory alors vous avez été convaincu
par jean les arguments de jean ray les
arguments de pierre houle et les
arguments qui ont été donnés sont bon
moi je pense que ce n'est pas un bon
tirage sur du les deux aspects carrément
alors sur l'aspect prestige suis
entièrement d'accord avec ce qui a été
dit on aurait bien sûr préféré pourquoi
pas un derby francilien voilà un petit
versailles paris saint germain ou un
versailles om pourquoi pas pour vous
faire plaisir pour les supporters
marseillais mais je pense qu'aussi
sportivement c'est pas un bon tirage je
vais m'expliquer on parle quand même du
deuxième de ligue 2 c'est une équipe
toulouse le tfc qui je pense fonde de
grands espoirs sur cette coupe de france
il ya moins de chances qu'une équipe
comme le tfc face tournée sur sur une
compétition comme la coupe de france
parce qu'elle veut aller l'arraché dans
la saison et donc moi pour moi le risque
et c'est ce qui me fait peur c'est que
versailles finalement parce que ce match
sera pas le plus reluisant se fasse un
peu éliminées dans l'anonymat sans gros
exploit ça a été dit et c'est ça aussi
les parcours de la coupe de france et
des dalles et pourquoi pas essayer
d'aller taper par dans l'expression mais
une équipe plus plus reluisante une
équipe de professionnels et là c'est une
équipe professionnelle de tfc mais ce
n'est pas une équipe de ligue 1 et j'ai
peur que versailles on va pas forcément
les mettre en avant peut-être la semaine
avant on est qu'ils se fassent éliminer
dans l'anonymat c'est ma crainte c'est
aussi pour ça se sentait un intrant
positive seulement qu'il reste dans
l'anonymat pour pouvoir l'étape et
unique de moi je pense que c'est un
tirage
pas idéal jeu j'aurais préféré dans le
même état dans la même visibilité des
équipes qui rencontrent une équipe comme
lens qui est en milieu de classement de
ligue 1 et qui a des difficultés cette
année plutôt qu'une équipe
professionnelle de ligue 2 et qui est
dans le haut du tableau de ligue 2 c'est
pas du tout du tout la même avec la même
dynamique seul prendre la tête de la
ligue 2 et voilà donc donc le tfc
aujourd'hui ils sont plein bourg et ça
tourne et on sait que la ligue 2 ça joue
sajou très physique et c'est donc bon
pour moi c'est ça j'aurais préféré qu'il
tombe sur une mauvaise équipe de ligue 1
qui ait réussi à s'en sortir sur sur les
sur les tours précédents plutôt que
plutôt qu'une très bonne équipe de ligue
2 et je pense que la difficulté sera là
maintenant le fait d'être en retrait au
niveau médiatique va peut-être jouer en
leur faveur et de ce fait à réussir à
créer à créer à nouveau la surprise
parce que c'est vrai que la dynamique de
cette de cette équipe de versailles et
est très belle et on peut déjà bien sûr
félicité ce parcours et simplement alors
c'est très très récent ce projet mais
c'est vrai que ça va je pense donner un
très beau souffle au projet de comparer
le projet c'est l'argent qui a été
injecté dans le club pour aller si vous
essayez le recteur j'ai des années en
ligue 2 par contre ce qu'on peut retenir
et ça a été dit par alors c'était le
capitaine que lequel devrait capitaine
ne versaient c'est oussama berkak là
c'était le capitaine marc elle mêle
durant de jeu vinet qui était capitaine
sur ce match de coupe de france c'est
intéressant ce qu'il disait c'est aussi
une belle aventure humaine et on sait
que c'est ça la coupe de france et les
garçons qui se connaissaient pas il ya
six mois c'est une équipe qui a été
largement renouvelée et on voit que très
vite l'osmose cfl solide car seul servir
ça peut le s'appelle solidifier sa peu
l'unifier et il ya des objectifs bien
plus important que la coupe de france
cette saison et c'est cette montée en
national et je pense que ce parcours
exceptionnel pourra les aider ça c'est
je pense le point positif aussi retenir
petite précision du coup ça ne sera pas
forcément un beau brun gregory r ça
dépend alors on sait que c'est le
week-end du 29-30 janvier la date reste
à affiner et tout dépendra de leur du
match si ça se joue en jeu on pourra
effectivement joué du côté de mont boron
mais on sait que si ça se joue en soirée
on ne peut pas utiliser l'éclairage on
l'a dit déjà de nombreuses fois dans
cette émission en raison des règles
concernant le château de versailles on
ne peut pas voir depuis la chambre de
louis xiv de lumière le soir voilà on va
pas se fâcher avec des historiens
dernière question tout simplement un
petit pronostic
on sait que que vous adorez sa
pronostics il ya du jarrier 2 0 pour
saint
pierre chevalier
défaite le vert 0,2 et vous genre
victoire et versailles partout et aux
tirs au but ok on attend le sticker de
cette évolution les pronostics les
gorilles mauvais allez on va dire des
fêtes de versailles de busan ok ils vont
se qualifier super on suivra donc
sauvage
attention ce match de coupe de france
sera programmée à la fin du mois le 29
ou le 30 janvier on passe à notre
prochain sujet on va parler cyclisme il
ya du jarrier je sais que vous êtes ravi
le parcours du paris nice 2022 a été
dévoilée ce mercredi 5 janvier le départ
sera donné le 6 mars depuis les i mean
pour la 13ème année consécutive les
cyclistes vont faire une boucle dans le
département départ de mantes-la-ville on
écoute françois lemarchand le directeur
de paris-nice une première boucle de 140
km alors on va aller au delà traverser
la seine au nord pour aller chercher une
partie du vexin puis après on va revenir
vers le tout chez apple val d'oise après
on va revenir vers revenir sur scène
donc la cdc des routes qu'on n'avait
jamais emprunté sur sur paris-nice donc
on va faire découvrir un petit peu le
département c'est normal faut que tout
le monde en profite après on ira sur ou
dans pour remonter ensuite sur sûrement
de la ville faire un passage sur une
arrivée pour les chercher
le circuit final de 20 km le lendemain
comme d'habitude c'est une petite
commune du département qui accueillera
le départ de l'épreuve cette année c'est
la petite commune d'auffargis qui aura
ce privilège un village de moins de 2000
habitants on écoute le responsable du
tracé françois lemarchand
moi même quand je quand je courais chez
les amateurs je cours beaucoup auffargis
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
qui qui qui parle au milieu cycliste ya
beaucoup de 2,2 groupe cycliste qui font
du vélo tout le week-end à loos dans
cette vallée de chevreuse qui passa
auffargis donc un petit clin d'oeil aux
farges et c'était sympa la question sur
ce thème est ce que le tracé vous plaît
messieurs chat oui ou non
ouï dire non
oui pour grégory vous êtes partagés yann
j'aime bien conservé je suis vous êtes
comme en visio
vous êtes vous êtes partagés bon c'est
pas trop ce que vous pensez
toujours à laurianne pourquoi alors vous
êtes le spécialiste cyclisme à la base
mais c'est vrai que j'aime bien et
j'aime bien quand comme je vois les
coureurs professionnels rouler sur la
vallée de chevreuse et sur les routes
que je peux en plus que je pouvais
emprunté il ya quelques années parce
qu'un effet en effet ces savants la
reprise du sport
notamment depuis je fais toutes les
pistes ont fait que j'ai beaucoup voient
passer beaucoup moins de temps sur la
route mais mais c'est vrai que c'est
toujours c'est toujours agréable de voir
à la télé des points que l'on connaît
des endroits des endroits des endroits
qu'on tourne à nous aussi pratiquer le
vélo donc là c'est vrai qu'ils vont être
sur le nord
le vexant c'est pas c'est pas simple
maintenant ça reste ça reste pour des
coureurs professionnels des parcours
très très sympa souvenez-vous l'année où
il était passé à bois d'arcy le parcours
était très très cassants et l'arrivée et
n était pas une
météo qui est lettré climatique et okc
beaucoup de plus voilà il y avait je
sais même pas s'il avait pas eu un peu
de neige beaucoup plus en tout cas c'est
ces deux mois de mars donc donc on verra
ce que ce que la météo nous apportera on
espère que ce sera comme lors du
contre-la-montre de coignières moi
j'aime bien c'est vrai que quand ils
font un petit prologue sur la sur la
1ère étape aussi ça fait quand même pas
mal d'années qu'il ne l'en qui ne l'ont
pas fait le dernier c'était c'était
coignières justement
j'espérais que ce soit un prologue pour
7 pour cette première étape bon ce sera
pas le cas ça fait maintenant maintenant
voilà oui
mantes-la-jolie pourquoi pas de toute
façon il faut paris-nice le lien entre
la vie pendant que la ville enfin paris
nice fait découvrir les légumes fait du
vélo dans les yvelines c'est de toute
façon très très bien genre vous est
mitigé sur cette question
est très mitigé aujourd'hui s'il reste
que le parcours vous semble le bon
techniquement je ne sais pas je ne suis
pas un spécialiste
techniquement certainement ensuite c'est
très bien qu'ils continuaient à passer
par
les endroits des civils qui sont qui
sont régulièrement
parcouru par les amateurs de cyclisme
tout le week-end dans la vallée de
chevreuse dante avant l'aube donc
c'était très bien on sait en plus que
c'est une des grandes compétitions de la
discipline le paris nice
avec de france mais paris nice ou paris
roubaix c'est celui de propre
compétition derrière pour de france donc
c'est très très bien c'est c'était une
bonne heure
c'est toujours on peut dire et c'est
spécial d'al l'idée du cyclisme de faire
découvrir des petits villages comme au
far gist
ça va démarrer là de faire découvrir le
village est de mettre en avant des cetc
petit village de l'entourent département
en tout cas on a vu qu'on l'a vu le
maire aujourd'hui à d'auffargis ils
étaient ravis d'accueillir la
compétition
à chaque fois le paris-nice passer par
sa commune mais là il part de sa commune
il est vraiment ravi a beau
clamer carton jaune carton jeu de jean
pierre chevallier
c'est pour poursuivre les propos de jeu
de gensse et c'est même dans l'adn de la
dr du cyclisme même même nous jean et
moi qui sommes pas des grands
spécialistes des grands fans de cyclisme
on sait qu on sait et on en parle
souvent sur ce plateau que que le que
les yvelines sont une terre de cyclisme
et que a priori c'est donc c'est dans
l'inconscient mais l'illinois de faire
du vélo d'une part pas pour tous et
d'assister à des courses et est
notamment de pouvoir mettre
en lumière deux villes de tailles
différentes c'est ces mêmes ces mêmes à
des as et inspirant c'est inspirant pour
les sports quand ils peuvent le faire
tac évidemment il n'y a pas de nya pas
de villes étapes dans tous les sports ça
se saurait mais en tout cas en cyclisme
de passer de mon clavier
auffargis que je ne connais pas que je
ne connais pas moi puisque je ne suis
pas cyclique donc je n'ai que je n'ai
pas parcouru ses routes ses rôties
lilloise c'est une c'est une très bonne
chose pour
j allais dire pour l'équité sportive et
en l'occurrence pour le spectacle et
pour la promotion de ce sport c'est une
c'est une très bonne chose et je précise
que c'est gratuit évidemment pour aller
voir en plus une pétition grégory peut
que se réjouir en tant que voilà
suiveurs du sport yvelinois que pour la
treizième année consécutive ça va passer
par les yvelines forcément on pouvait
avoir peur d'eux est ce qu'ils vont
réussir à se renouveler mais force est
de constater qu'ils arrivent quand même
à se renouveler il arrive à mettre en
avant aussi des villes de tailles
différentes ça a été dit l'année
dernière on était sur une formule
différente c'était plutôt une ville de
la zone de versailles comme saint cyr
l'école qui a été mise en avant est une
petite commune du nord des yvelines où
un livre sur mansion là vous voyez qu'on
a inversé on a plutôt favorisé une
grosse commune du nord des yvelines est
une petite commune du sud yvelines donc
on arrive à faire le tour des yvelines
et on peut être que content là c'est
vrai ils ont emprunté des routes qui
n'ont jamais été utilisés pour un paris
nice par exemple par exemple ou dans non
si je dis pas de bêtises non c'est
simple je ne sais pas mais je sais qu'il
ya quelques petits trucs qui n'ont pas
encore utilisé pour pour le paris nice
donc non on peut que bien sûr se
satisfaire que ce tracé passe encore et
une nouvelle fois par les yvelines on
arrive à se renouveler quand même yann
ça fait 13 ans quand même que le parent
et 10 passes je ne suis pas
dessinateur de parcours donc je ne je ne
sais pas s'ils arrivent à se renouveler
ce qui est sûr c'est que les coureurs
eux gardent en tête les endroits
stratégiques les endroits difficiles
parce que même s'il parcourt entre 20 et
30 mille kilomètres par an sur un sur un
vélo sachez bien que quand on leur quand
ils vont quand ils vont à la
présentation du tour de france et qui
voit le tracé le tracé ce faire ils
savent qu'elles sont l'école qui sont
empruntés et donc tout de suite ils
savent qu'ils commencent à va pas
comment la course se passera mais ce
qu'il y aura à faire comme comme étape
donc là c'est vrai que les gars la
veille quand il regarde le road book il
y a des points qu'ils connaissent et
qu'ils maîtrisent déjà les arrivées dans
les villes alors sont parfois aussi un
petit peu modifié par le biais de
l'importance de la compétition dans
laquelle il participe il peut y avoir
d'aidé des ronds-points ou alors des des
gendarmes couchés qui peuvent être
enlevés pour pour certaines épreuves
mais mais voilà les les coureurs
connaissent connaissent les endroits où
ils où il pratique parce que on est à
cette mémoire et on se souvient on se
souvient de de tout ça en tout cas le
paris nice passera par les yvelines
jusqu'en 2025 avec le contrat signé
entre le département et à esso et on
sera évidemment présent début mars pour
couvrir ce paris nice on passe à notre
page débats
[Musique]
un mot de boxe à présent est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour tony yoka le
boxeur originaire de chanteloup les
vignes ne boxera finalement pas le 15
janvier prochain lacan arena de paris
bercy contre le congolais un martin
bacot les le combat était reportée à
cause de la crise sanitaire de la mise
en place d'une jauge de 2000 spectateurs
pour le sport à l'intérieur ce qui
remettait en question l'équilibré
financier de l'événement tony yoka
estime avoir pris un petit coup au moral
mais ils affirment être prêts à
combattre les plus grands on le voit un
peu nigaud car avant c'était martin
partie de ma colère je le précise la
question sur cette thématique tony hawk
à est-il malchanceux finalement
oui ou non ces derniers mois
oui pour vous grégory oui pour vous à
pierre non pour vous yann et jean et oui
pour vous il est malchanceux ont fait un
petit duel entre gens viennent à les
gens vont commencer
les gens vont commencer
les matches est celui sur qui est match
est ce parce que lui lui lui pour lui
pour la pour pour la progression de sa
carrière et pour pouvoir les affronter
justement on en a parlé plusieurs fois
pour vouloir pouvoir affronter les
meilleurs
il est obligé de passer par ce combat là
et pour lui ça va retarder une fois de
plus les chaises de montrer qui fait
partie des grandes et que
malheureusement il est malchanceux parce
qu'il dit pour y est c'est pas c'est pas
de sa faute si c'est reporté
ensuite la raison pour laquelle j'ai
remporté ses six et 2000 c'est parce que
y arrive on ne peut plus accueillir plus
de 2000 je pense aussi et surtout au
niveau des équilibres financiers en jeu
précise c'est l'écran gros fixé au
niveau de l' équilibre financier de
l'événement voilà c'est ça ouais c'est
ce que j'allais dire 2000 je pense
qu'avec 2000 il rentrait pas au niveau
financier d'un bandana les fermetures et
rapporter parce qu'ils vivent pas
d'amour et d'eau fraîche ces gens là
donc sauf que oui pour moi une madjer ce
mois il est malchanceux il est
malchanceux et ça risque quand même
malgré malgré ses déclarations qu'il est
prêt à affronter n'importe qui ça risque
quand même de lui porter préjudice pour
la suite de sa carrière n'en parlera
juste après alien jean m'a convaincu
oui bien sûr que c'est pas de bol
maintenant à leur niveau c'est d'aider
des combattants qui sont capables de
faire des combats tous les trois mois à
peu près enfin c'est des athlètes qui
devaient de faire des combats des
combats toutes et tous les trois mois
les gros boxeur faut environ trois
combats par an maximum voilà donc du
coup oui en effet il prend un peu mais
c'est trois mois de retard il a déjà
perdu un an à cause de ces no show et
leno show c'est pas 2 c'est pas de la ma
chance c'est juste un mauvais
encadrement ou 120 banques membres là on
est rentré antidopage donc donc étant
déjà perdu un temps il n'est plus à
trois mois près pour moi donc oui en
effet bien le combat où les d'avoir eu
au mois de janvier ben il aura peut-être
un autre et peut-être même un meilleur
combat au mois de mars au mois d'avril
ou peut-être qu'il pourra combattre à
nouveau ce cet adversaire au mois de mai
au mois de mars au mois d'avril c'est
pas c'est pas grave c'est trois mois
c'est sait rien quand grégory je pense
qu'il est mal chansons en tout cas sur
ce combat là
un combat qui aurait pu lui permettre j
pas forcément de passer dans une
nouvelle dimension mais en tout cas non
non non c'est pour ça que je salue ça
lui aurait pas forcément donner plus de
crédit mais ça l'aurait renforcer
peut-être dans sa confiance il a été
malchanceux sur ce qu'on rend ce combat
là parce qu'à la base il faut rappeler
aussi con il devra affronter carlos
takam qui est plutôt à l'orée de sa
carrière il a fini sa carrière mais qui
a quand même une belle carrière qui a un
nom qui qui qui connut dans la boxe et
finalement par une blessure c'est martin
bacot les qu'il l'avait remplacé donc
déjà c'était un premier élément de
malchance et en plus de ça la deuxième
élément de malchance ce combat qui est
reportée équivalent freiné je pense dans
sa progression en tout cas lui se voyait
déjà avec une ceinture mondiale en 2022
là ça n'arrivera pas un peu on peut
l'affirmer ici sur ce plateau que ça
n'arrivera pas même s'il est en
confiance et qui dit qui peut aller
combattre je suis à 50 fois ça va être
difficile de le voir avoir un tel combat
en 2022 pierre chevallier qui vous a
convaincu je
suis plutôt de l'avis de deux jalons
parce que évidemment on pousse la
malchance elle peut avoir plusieurs
visages la lui c'est une question de
calendrier une question d'épidémie
pandémie - bien que personne ne pouvait
prévoir et ça donne ça donne un
déséquilibre financier qui rend qui rend
une soirée de boxe
pas rentable et on s'aime on s'est calé
à quel point à quel point le
l'organisation de combats est basé aussi
sur une rupture de land art diamond est
sûre vu données financières et elle peut
avoir un deuxième visage c'est que en
attendant
vous devez moss et hakam comme comme
disait comme disait greg il en suit donc
c'est ma collègue 7e mondial et cette
malchance lalo poursuit jusque jusque
dans la réponse dans sa réputation de
boxeur on a on a à priori on en a déjà
travaillé sur ce plateau là il est
victime des victimes en gros de cette
malchance globale sur sur le niveau des
boxeurs qui a qui lui sont opposés on
dit souvent qu'ils boxent des videurs de
boîte de nuit où des vies dans deux
supermarchés
récemment il en est justement ému et
c'est c'est plus qu'agacé en essayant de
mettre les points sur les i dans les
journaux dans les journaux sportifs pour
accompagner vos propos à pierre
chevalier les mecs qui disent que je
boxe des vigiles de supermarchés sont
des bobos cessation des sondés mauvais
de l'as rome il a rappelé aussi que que
son père il était boxeur la fin de sa
carrière là était donc il ya beaucoup de
respect aussi pour les eaux les vigiles
et donc avec c'est avec ces combats qui
sont ils sont annulés ou reportés on ne
sait pas
rien qu'avec va coller en 17e mondial ça
retarde l'échéance dont parlait le don
par les ja no 2 de pouvoir de pouvoir
boxer une tête d'affiche dit tyson fury
du ou du joshua et et puis c'est ça le
montre moins que pour l'instant il a
effectivement un petit caillou dans la
chaussure avec 7 cette année cette année
purgatoire qui est qu'ils assurent là
pour le coup c'est pas la malchance qui
la subit il a subi contraint et forcé le
coup mais là il ya un petit peu de
responsabilité aussi je pense voilà il
ne peut pas redorer son blason mais
quand même champion olympique palettes
ou ne l'oublions pas il a carrément déjà
il a déjà un joli palmarès mais il dans
la boxe professionnelle du monde il lui
manque un
un grand nom à son palmarès et est il
alors des droits anthony je suis à l'un
des meilleurs boxeurs au monde
à cette arme de plus en plus de temps
qu'il a passé ses combats là c'est son
boulot c'est de deux je vais pas dire de
leur faire offense à tous mais en tout
cas des les combats - remy longtemps
qu'il les a peu fait et il prend du
retard sur son tableau de marche donc là
oui c'est de la malchance global de
tomber en plus dans une période de kovy
qui khirbat toutes les cartes dans tous
les sports ne riez pas mais j'ai quand
même une question c'est pour vous qui
connaissez pourquoi les têtes d'affiché
on ne veulent pas combattre contre
contre tony yoka est ce que c'est parce
que il n'a pas entre guillemets laura
suffisant pour pouvoir déplacer les
foules et remplir une salle qui
permettrait de faire vivre un combat de
leur niveau ou simplement est-ce qu'ils
n'ont pas peur de combattre contre tony
yoka parce que en effet les gens plus
olympique il prouve que sur ses combats
il est quand même capable de 2,2 de
remporter de remporter même si ses
adversaires mais quand on le voit il est
quand même c'est pas c'est pas un gars
qui cas de la bedaine ou cocasse on voit
que c'est quand même un athlète qui il
travaille futé moi je me dis c'est mais
en voyant qu'un adversaire qui veut le
combat pourquoi ce qui le pourquoi ce
qu'ils ne le font pas on sait que c'est
votre modèle pour 2022 le jariel
griffoul à se répandre ouais c'est pas
forcément d'explication je pencherais
plutôt pour la première où il n'a pas
encore je pensais tu auras mondiale pour
remplir des salles je pense que ça peut
être une première son explication il ya
sûrement aussi j'enlève également
puisque les propos de grégory qu au
niveau du classement il n'y a aucun
intérêt pour les tops le top-5
d'affronter tony yoka sinon à bruxelles
ce soir et je partage tout ce à quoi je
parle même plus de quatre top-5 et
laurence quoi voilà on sait qu'il ya ce
mec là qui qui fait du bruit qui qui est
présent qu'il était champion olympique
pourquoi est ce qu'on a moi j'ai
l'impression avec mon regard de non
spécialistes de la boxe que ses
adversaires ont peut-être peur de le
rencontrer mais dans ce monde là on sait
très bien que la carte marketing était
en est énormément importante avec des
promoteurs aussi qui organise ces
combats moi je pensais plutôt son aura
encore qui est pas bon à dire au niveau
international après joshua on peut
comprendre aussi qui ça les démange de
d'affronter joshua qui a perdu son
dernier combat ton contre musique donc
on a commencé à avoir un jeu au choix
avec des défaillances des difficultés
donc je peux comprendre aussi qu'il soit
en pleine confiance et qui qui va y
aller très très vite a raconté anthony
le choc n'a pas répondu pour l'instant à
la sollicitation de tony yoka sur un
possible combat dernière chose peut-être
jean j'aimerais vous faire réagir par
rapport à la fois on en a parlé très
brièvement juste avant les mecs qui
disent que je boxe vigile de supermarché
sont des bobos je sais que vous avez eu
souvent ces propos là ici sur sur ce
plateau quelle est votre réaction
vous étiez plus vite et ans de boîte de
nuit
voilà mais non mais c'est ce que c'est
ce qu'il connaît tous plus ou moins
l'habitude de dire maintenant je pense
qu'il a dit ça parce qu'il est un petit
peu excédé que il a jeu parce qu'au fond
de lui il a envie de montrer de prouver
et il n'attend qu'une chose c'est ce se
mesurer aux grandes aux très graves
savoir que vraiment s'il fait partie de
7,7 de cette génération de grands
boxeurs ou pas et qu' il ne peut excéder
quand les gens disent c'est un boxeur
tout simplement mais malheureusement
pour l'instant je les dis ça va encore
retarder et puis il ya aucun intérêt
pour les grands boxeurs de boxer n tony
yoka aujourd'hui aucun intérêt
on va maintenant passer à l'envolée de
grégory le moment le plus incroyable
puis dantesque de cette émission de quoi
allez vous nous parlez à grégory thil en
ce début 2022 j'aimerais présenter mes
meilleurs voeux meilleurs sportifs pour
cette année que 2022 soit pleine de
bonnes nouvelles pour les athlètes
yvelinois plein de très beaux résultats
a commencé forcément on en parlait tout
à l'heure par le fc versa et quelle
première moitié de saison les hommes de
youssef schibbye sont déjà rentrés dans
l'histoire en se qualifiant en huitièmes
de finale de la coupe de france de
football en face désormais le tfc fin
janvier pour se hisser pourquoi pas
parmi les huit dernières équipes de la
compétition ce serait exceptionnel je
précise voilà qu'on n'avait pas les
images de du rugby-club de versailles
mais enfin j'en avais les images du
rugby-club de versailles et panon exerça
sur parler du football club de versets
si on peut envoyer bien sûr
ça y est dans un premier temps je le
disais un parcours exceptionnel en coupe
de france sans oublier qu'en championnat
le club est en course pour une montée en
national et qui est bien placé
d'ailleurs pour le moment ils sont
deuxièmes de nationale 2 être dans la
troisième division française passée
ferait passer seul fcv justement dans
une autre dimension je leur souhaite
genou le souhaitent aussi parce que ça
nous amènerait bien sûr beaucoup de
beaux débats en perspective
en plateau bon on a un peu grillé la
surprise j'en suis désolé mais fortis
inc comment parler de versailles sans
évoquer le rugby-club nos amis du rugby
club de versailles 1 le rc versailles
cette fois ci qui est aussi bon leader
alors versailles foot est deuxième et
versailles rugby est bon leader de sa
poule une en fédérale 3 8 victoires 0
défaite quand je vois les résultats de
nos clubs de la cité royale d'ailleurs
me demande s'ils ont eu droit au même
vaccin que nous je sais pas si pierre à
une réponse à nous apporter blague à
part on aimerait fortement que le rcv
rejoigne plaisir en fédérale 2 la
quatrième division nationale de rugby
jean n'est pas terminé avec le rugby
club de versailles j'espère qu'un de vos
plus beaux produits continue sa
progression cette année je veux parler
bien sûr de lier au bar et 19 ans le
trois-quarts polyvalent a obtenu
beaucoup de temps de jeu jusqu'à présent
avec le stade français il faut que ça se
poursuive lui qui devait discuter qui
devrait normalement disputer le tournoi
des six nations des moins de 20 ans
avant pourquoi pas d'accéder un jour
c'est tout le mal qu'on peut lui
souhaiter au quinze de france à
excellente année également 2022 et très
bon tournoi des six nations et emilie
boulard l'ariary blinois sera
normalement de la partie avec l'équipe
de france féminine qui disputera en plus
cette année une coupe du monde en
nouvelle zélande son bilan en 2021 6
sélections trois essais de quoi rêver en
2022 dans la progression on attend
forcément avec impatience la suite de la
saison de notre grand espoir du basket
français le joueur de l'asvel
victor webb anyama mais je suis surtout
pressé de voir la suite des événements
pour deux autres athlètes yvelinois gelé
surnommerait notre double ce que vous
avez une idée le double r jan
hauser et le 2e
antoine runner le golfeur bien sûr
qu'ils repartent déjà sur de bons rails
en 2022 après une saison 2021 contrastée
il est actuel 117e mondial je pense
qu'on peut le voir largement plus haut
sa victoire en mars dernier au qatar le
prouve tout comme son succès on s'en
rappelle avec brighton de chant beau
championnat du monde de match play le
deuxième r c'est arthur rinderknecht
d'ailleurs je sais pas si c'est un
hasard mais on peut dire que c'est un
hasard ils ont les mêmes initiales avec
antoine retenait reims approuve
peut-être que les airs bibis noires sont
vouées au succès et une progression
fulgurante on s'en souvient en 2021 pour
le tennisman
j'en ai même fait mon sportif de l'année
est désormais 58e mondial appelé en bleu
aussi bien en coupe davis quand atp cup
en ce début d'année même s'il n'ya pas
eu forcément beaucoup de réussite le
saint germanois va repartir pour une
nouvelle saison on espère un top 30
mondial pourquoi pas les rêves sont
permis
enfin ça va plaire à yann en octobre le
vélodrome national recevra déjà pour la
deuxième fois de sa jeune histoire les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste en 2015 le moment a été magique
cette médaille pour l'équipe de france
dont 5 en or devant un public bouillant
25000 spectateurs s'étaient pressés dans
les travées saint quentinois sur les
cinq jours de compétition ce serait beau
de voir le même succès populaire à
l'automne à saint quentin en yvelines
mais pour que tout ça se réalise bien
sûr avec de belles images un public au
rendez vous mon principal veut il n'est
pas forcément sportives pour cette année
2022 il pourrait concerner le sport et
j'en terminerai par là c'est de voir la
fin de cette épidémie est de colis de 19
elle nous prive de débats passionnés
aujourd'hui en plateau on le voit on
n'est que trois avec les masques en plus
pour ce début d'année à lacets impact
aussi forcément tiré sur le monde du
sport on aimerait les retirer ces
masques avec eux donc je le disais un
impact sur le sport de nombreux sportifs
aussi qui sont contaminés en ce début
d'année on pense bien sûr forcément eu
du ballet le commis 19 août a assez vu
pour l'instant et voilà j'espère que
tous ses voeux vont se réaliser et je
souhaite à toutes et à tous une bonne
année 2009
votre avis sur ses voeux
c'est tout ce que vous souhaitez il ya
déjà rayé je note juste une chose c'est
que en effet donc versailles rugby
versailles foot premier et deuxième je
me souviens quand on a commencé cette
émission il ya cinq ans on avait
beaucoup beaucoup de clubs qui
redescendent est plutôt et et ça remonte
et c'est vrai que on était dans une
spirale négative sur les i mean et là
j'ai quand même l'impression que alors
j'ai pas dire c'est parce qu'on en parle
mais c'est vrai que bah si les clubs ont
des bons résultats on parlera d'eux
parce que c'est vrai que maintenant on
suit beaucoup de versailles sportif le
versailles rugby le versailles de foot
on suit pas mal de clubs de la région
des attaques qui ont des résultats et
c'est vrai que j'espère que ça va
encourager des autres avoir mené dans un
bercy clos sinon je ne sais pas le
vaccin versailles et du coup fatal
chevallier
on appelle ça le pot belge donc c'est un
mix des jamais payé des call box inconnu
et effectivement c'est en fait ça des
tours de potion magique en
tout cas très très belle envolée de greg
pour moi je suis je suis comblé et
heureux parce que les trois premiers du
classement ont des versailles et si on
ajoute évidemment le football de
versailles le rugby versailles et les
homards et qui est un versailles est
formé
formé à porsche fontaine avant d'aller à
massy et au stade français est en train
de rentrer à qui et à la boulie donc pas
si loin que versailles en force
effectivement il ya d'essayer d'avoir
leur a pris sa pas toujours été le cas
sap a tous été le cas donc effectivement
je ne peux qu'abonder dans le sens de
grégory avec alex et veut que l'on
n'espère pas 28e mais justement d eux qu
qui sont en fait et c'est celle à
caboter sont réalisables dire que
parfois les veaux sont des voeux ils
sont trop ambitieux comme celui de
perdre du poids ou
2 arrêter de fumer par exemple mais là
en l'occurrence ce sont des voeux qui
sont réalisables c'est évidemment tout
ce que je souhaite pour le sport
illinois et notamment en particulier
pour le sport et les recettes genre
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ses voeux
mais fameux famille le fils situation
aggravée j'ai très bien joué pour le
mieux
donc en gros si j'ai pour résumer faut
être versés rien pour réussir dans le
sport
non mais bon
on le dit mais pas parce que c'est bien
c'est avec versailles est une belle
ville sportive des yvelines sinon la
plus belle ça me faire ça faire
enregistrer ça
on va passer à la dernière partie de
cette émission alors lui n'est pas
versailles et il est rempli temps louis
burton souvenez vous début novembre le
bureau ovale et 3 le bateau au bureau
vallée 3 du navigateur évinois avait
démâté alors qu'il occupait la deuxième
place sur la transat jacques vabre 2021
un incident survenu en pleine nuit
quelques heures après le départ après
plusieurs semaines d'investigations
la raison est désormais connu louis
burton a confié à nos confrères de
voiles et voiliers qu'un câble de voile
jitrois sûre et responsable de la voirie
le bas a pris 10 degrés de plus car ils
n'étaient pas retenues vers l'avant un
système de crochets n'aurait pas
fonctionné d'après les premiers indices
est ce que ça vous surprend déjà ya
dujarrier que ça puisse ça puisse
arriver alors vous êtes spécialiste
cyclisme également voir ces derniers
mois passionnant la solution de vote
depuis le vendée globe que depuis le
vendée globe depuis la dernière édition
du vendée globe en effet je suis pas
assez technique simplement moi ce qui me
rassure c'est d'avoir trouvé la raison
et je pense que c'est ça qui est le plus
important c'est que aujourd'hui ils
savent ils ont pu identifier la
problématique est là d'où venaient les
avaries c'est vrai que quand on l'a
quand vous êtes dans une voiture qu'elle
fait un bruit suspect que vous ne savez
pas vous êtes toujours inquiet
vous dites qu est-ce que qu'est ce qui
va me lâcher afin d'identifier bas c'est
bon on peut réparer ben là on n'est même
pas sûr une voiture on est sur une
formule 1 des mers et rose voiture une
grosse voiture et donc je pense que
voilà sur le ghana maintenant louis
burton va voir qu'une seule envie c'est
de repartir alors il va pouvoir faire
des essais mais donc se rendre compte
que son bateau répond de la bonne
manière et maintenant il va avoir envie
de repartir sur une prochaine une
prochaine compétition pour la pour
pouvoir montrer qu' il y sera dans le
dos relais sur les podiums de chaque
épreuve qu'il disputera
sur le côté rassurant ça pourrait venir
effectivement d'un défaillance peut-être
technique de ce crochet peut-être une
défaillance humaine aussi c'est possible
l'erreur est humaine comme comme dit le
précieux adage est donc c'est rassurant
dans le france qu on l'a dit sur ce
plateau louis burton navigue sur un
nouveau bateau on aurait pu craindre que
la défaillance viennent directement de
ce nouveau bateau qu'il venait à décrire
juste après ce vendée globe est en soi
c'est rassurant maintenant ils ont
identifié
d'où venait ce problème ils vont pouvoir
travailler pour que ça ne se reproduise
plus à l'avenir est en soi en soit c'est
rassurant pour ça quand j'ai lu comme
j'ai lu que c'était une erreur humaine
et ça m'a inquiété parce que je me suis
dit on essaie de noyer le noyer le bébé
alors que là non voilà on est pas sûr à
100% non mais oh moi au moins il ya
quand même des explications c'est
identifier ceux qui sont touchés par le
vote noir ça veut dire que voilà il ya
un capteur sur chaques sur chaque
crochet sur chaque mois ça fait beaucoup
de vagues sur le bastion
genre
oui alors moi pour moi
deux choses où c'est une erreur
technique une erreur technique ça ça
fait partie du jeu la navigation
et on le sait on ne sait malheureusement
les erreurs techniques ça fait partie
c'est comme le tarn comme les conditions
climatiques donc là il n'y pouvait rien
malheureusement ça fait partie par
contre si c'est une erreur humaine si tu
veux il est en faute professionnelle
parce que là il y en a là rien de la
souligner c'est les formules 1 rue de la
mer c'est comme si vous oubliez de
bisser les roues sur la formule 1 ajout
vrillé du carry le rouet le virage donc
là c'est
un bref je précise qu'ils étaient deux
sur le bateau ses senneurs y avait
également des guy beaudart était pas
tout seul sur le bateau alors
où des portes c'est peut-être ce sont
eux qui voient là
un assistant qui à kamal qui a peut-être
légal oui c'est être dans la préparation
du bateau aussi jusqu'à la ruine et ce
en fait rien je voyais ces préparations
ou patinoire humaine le professionnel
pierre
sait où on en parlait de louis burton
dans le classement il ya quinze jours le
classement des sportifs des sportifs de
l'année du sportif rhinois de l'année ça
rappelle à quel point
cessé
ses monstrueuses athlètes que sont les
que sont les voileux son dépendance
dépendant de la technique là d'accord
avec yann c'est bien d'avoir trouvé
parce que ça va permettre ça va
permettre d'améliorer un petit peu de
notions du système pour les prochaines
courses mais en tout cas ça a été c'est
halo est rageant
de d'avoir de subir ce type de dammarie
et de problèmes techniques erreur
humaine ou pas d'un technicien de
l'équipe
les 1000 peu importe mais ne voir à quel
point ce sont des fabuleuses athlètes
mais qui sont aussi dépendants de leurs
machines et de la préparation des
machines alors les équipes de louis
burton essaye désormais de réparer au
plus vite les dégâts pour qu'il puisse
revenir en mer le plus rapidement
possible on parle peut-être du mois
d'avril du mois de mai peut-être est-ce
que ça vous paraît envisageable ian
si je trouve ça m est ce que c'est bien
ça y est je vois d'avril à naviguer moi
je roule chez l'homme après voilà jeu
j'imaginais que c'était déjà réparé et
qui pouvaient déjà et qui les dés
étaient déjà en train de naviguer quand
il pour s'entraîner donc en effet
c'était une très grosse avarie quand
quand tout va mal voilà donc je
sais ouais c'est vrai faut tout faire
pour port est pas non plus la route du
rhum arrive au mois de novembre grégory
très rapidement est ce qu'on pensait
qu'il sera sur la ligne de départ mais
il sait pas il se rassure ligne de
départ doit être sur la ligne de départ
parce que on sait qu'il va pas y avoir
50 compétition d'ici le vendée globe qui
a un objectif affiché et qui se
déroulera en 2024 donc il faut qu'ils
sachent sur les plus grosses courses qui
puisse être sur les prochains mois et la
prochaine grande course c'est la route
du rhum et donc il faut qu'il soit sur
les une deuxième par une préparation
c'est très bien mais mes novembre cinq
mois ça va
concerner rendez vous fin novembre pour
louis burton c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission on va terminer comme d'habitude
par une citation aujourd'hui pour la
première de l'année je vous propose une
citation du sulfureux footballeur george
best j'ai dépensé beaucoup d'argent dans
la boisson les filles et les voitures de
sport et le reste je les gaspiller
chedjou à la civilité sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 68 et surtout un très
bonnes années ici
[Musique]